la onu envió un mensaje urgente al
ejército de mianmar donde las revueltas
sociales en contra del golpe de estado
dejan hasta ahora cuatro muertos
incluido en policía y decenas de heridos
olvido al ejército de myanmar que
detenga inmediatamente la represión que
libere a los prisioneros y acabe con la
violencia que respete los derechos
humanos y la voluntad del pueblo
expresada en las últimas elecciones
guterres también dijo que el mundo es
testigo del socavamiento de la
democracia en mianmar el uso de la
fuerza brutal y graves violaciones
contra minorías sin rendición de cuentas
incluyendo lo que se ha llamado limpieza
de la población rojilla la junta militar
que subió al poder tras derrocar a la
líder birmana se pronunció en la
televisión estatal acusando a los
manifestantes de aumentar su incitación
a la revuelta y a la muchedumbre
anárquica aseguró además que el camino
de la confrontación supondrá la pérdida
de vidas
a través de 'twitter' el relator
especial de la onu se mostró preocupado
por el mensaje del ejército birmano
estoy profundamente preocupado por esta
horrible advertencia pública de la junta
de que los manifestantes están incitando
al pueblo a un camino de confrontación
donde sufrirán la pérdida de vidas a
diferencia de 1988 las acciones de las
fuerzas de seguridad se están grabando y
ustedes serán responsables
miles de manifestantes volvieron a las
calles este lunes en una huelga nacional
marcada por un fin de semana en el que
dos personas perdieron la vida el
consejo de derechos humanos de la onu
debe discutir posibles sanciones al
ejército golpista que hasta ahora ha
rechazado todas las condenas de la
comunidad internacional